today's topic so i did a live where i
asked people men
and women why they use only fence and so
today we're going to be covering
why she uses only fans hello
oh man this is so unreal yes ma'am so
why do you pay for only fans
um because it's cool for real
what do you mean gotta help out some
some moms
that's my [ __ ] right there i don't even
know why
there's something by the voice yeah
there's something about the swagger
that i could just this my [ __ ] i don't
even know why
it reminds me of i don't know what it is
hey but the way
the way this choice she said cause it's
cool whatever
that's my [ __ ] i don't know why i'm
pretty sure that we have the same type
of girl that we're looking at
some girls that just you know maybe
exhibitionists you just gotta help them
out
see them then move on your business you
know
it's not really that much of a big deal
you pay for a service
you get service and then you go about
your business
so do you watch do you watch their
content you'd be like damn that's
struggling mom let me see her let me see
your ass
that's my [ __ ]
[Music]
bro 100
you know it's
he's been selling since the dawn of time
all right
are you are you are you into women
i'm into everybody man yeah i really
like hentai i'm not even going to lie
you like i like hentai but i have like
you know huh i like hentai
for real but you know there's a certain
like people like you see their instagram
and [ __ ] and they're like oh they got
they're nice you want to see y'all all
right cool
i'll help him out
do you got any uh youtubers you support
like that
i mean no not you though i do instagram
if i watch youtube it's for like you
yeah kevin samuel that's not what i
asked do you have any youtubers that you
support financially
oh no if i would i would support
you and and and and preach what if we
were showing some [ __ ] goals
if we were showing some dick and balls
on patreon would you support
i mean yeah cause i mean yeah cuz i just
want to see it because i'll be curious
cut this [ __ ] off that's my [ __ ] that's
my [ __ ]
listen you're invited to the cookout
whatever the [ __ ] you is you my [ __ ]
and i know there's a lot of [ __ ]
out there they're gonna be like yeah but
if it was a guy you'd be like you'd be
calling him a sam it's
all the question of demeanor if i be
like you a sim she'd be like
whatever i don't care she wouldn't care
like that so i could roll with that i
don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] just like you if you were to do it
you know i'd be like
i wonder what the sickest balls look
like
[Laughter]
you know you just curious you know no no
i don't know i mean i'm
not i'm not listen nothing like you
you're just wondering
i'll ask you i i'll be watching
youtubers like that
i mean i wonder what man i wonder what i
put i never i don't think that but
i'm not gonna pay for it no it's not
true i would
and it's in a setting the proper said
you go to [ __ ] bar or whatever
i would have yeah yeah but it's just i
think it's the same thing what's the
difference you know what i mean
like that's why and i told you that i
don't give a sh i don't give a [ __ ] like
that
i don't care about if you pay
to have a service i don't care about
that
and that's not what i see what i see the
the definition
of simping is paying for a service
that's not it to me that's not it that i
cringe whenever people call it
oh he's simply simping he's that's not
what i call
simping is when you put that person on
the pedestal
when you're like oh that person has
everything and i just that person just
does nothing and you just be like oh my
god oh my god
it's the next chance of service so i
don't see it as simping yo how about i
tell you
the most alpha guys famous dudes they
fly girls out they pay for their meals
they pay for them to go shopping smash
them and leave and for those guys you
wouldn't say they're stimping
and if you did you don't know what
you're talking about for them it's
convenience you know let me put some
money on this girl
she gonna come in she's gonna do the
work and then she's gonna leave and i'm
good with it so
to to me it's just convenience that's
why i pay
so you don't bug me that's what that's
that's that's what i'm saying is you
don't want to have
it's not me because if you go it's messy
if you're going to the whole like if you
get to a level whenever you got money or
whatever whatnot you just want to be
transacting with a girl you just want
that [ __ ] to be transactional sometimes
you just want something to be done real
quick right quick right if you get into
the feelings and stuff like that
things get complicated it's not easy
peasy lemon squeezy
it gets difficult difficult lemon
difficult you understand and that's what
they want
easy yeah nah you just wonder i wonder
how big this
big this [ __ ] dick look like you know
how big is his dick what does his dick
look like when he poses in the bathroom
maybe if he slaps it on the counter you
know
she said slap sit on the counter
i want to see how this [ __ ] did look
like
yo yo the demeanor the delivery
everything is a hundred i love it
he with his friend i think you
you and um preach should do like um but
not all the way naked
but great pants gray sweatpants episodes
yes dude i've been saying that since i
was in like middle school
like what 15 years ago like guys are the
[ __ ] when they wear
gray pants that's their [ __ ] outfits
how much would you pay to see us in
sweatpants and grace weapons
you know because i like y'all i'll
probably pay like
like like five bucks for real just cause
it's a gag cause you ain't serious about
it
but if you were serious with your
clothes off i'll probably pay
15 20. okay just because i want to say
yo i saw that [ __ ] dick for real
he decent dog he decent
i think she's from new york something
like that yeah definitely east coast i
think she's from jersey
100 east coast cannot give me a new york
accent but i'm just guessing she live in
new york new jersey
okay i'm mad at you i go as low as
version okay me
i'm going i'm going new york philly
philly that's the one i was looking for
but lo the lowest would be virginia you
said new jersey
i said the new jersey virginia anyways i
just want to say
it was interesting um we talked to a few
women who use only fans but not too many
if you want to we're going to do another
live
so if you'd like to share why you ladies
do it feel free to jump on we want to
hear from you guys
uh and i'm also going to have a video
well i should already be out the video
with why the guys do only things
i i i'd have a i would have an idea i'd
have an idea i
had an idea for only fans but it was
just me
doing dishes only pans
that's just me doing dishes okay well
listen if you guys would be interested
let us know in the comments below if you
want to watch preach do some dishes if
that turns you on
and then maybe we'll set that up think
about it
other than that yeah it was interesting
and she was really cool about it and i
think
doing these lives and learning about why
people use only fans was interesting for
me
it kind of made it more clear because i
think you hear all the same objections
why would you pay for it if it's free
online because it's more personalized
that's what it really comes down to you
feel like you're getting something
exclusive it makes people feel special
so why people buy memorabilia that you
you could watch a comic or read a comic
online or you could just
buy it pay 15 bucks for some people it's
important to own the property or
whatever like
there's different layers to how much
people want proximity to whatever it is
that they're into so
it's been interesting that's all i'm
going to say but she was funny she was
awesome and loved having but it's not
easy
like you know there's all the whole
downsides because it's not just posting
pics sometimes you know you have to
have interaction with the people with
the only thing and it can get very
draining and [ __ ] like that so it's not
all
it's not all easy fun and games yes but
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below
uh we want to hear from you
[Music]
why you wanna be a player
i'll be the one